So, I get a lot of questions about,
"Why are these stones so dirty?"
This is not dirt. These
are living organisms.
These are plants.
The more polished the stone,
the less surface area there is
for the biological organisms
to adhere to the stone.
And so the reason why we use
this quaternary ammonium
compound is this kills them.
So, these things are natural in nature.
You're going to find in
the South especially,
it's not just growing on rooftops,
it's also growing on our headstones.
My name is Trae Zipperer.
I'm the founder of By Memorial Day,
a nonprofit organization
dedicated to the cleaning
of all veteran headstones by
Memorial Day in perpetuity.
So, this is a ground-level grave marker
issued by the federal government
via the National Cemetery Administration.
It's a white marble
material, natural stone.
He was a gunner's mate,
GM, third class, US Navy.
I don't think it's respectful to have
a veteran's headstone dirty in the least.
And so we're going to clean this headstone
of this American hero who gave his all,
who sacrificed unimaginable horrors
for three and a half years
as a prisoner of war.
The first thing I like to do is
I use a desk broom
to get all of the sand and
debris off of the stone.
So, we take our water-squirt bottle.
I like the one with a little
bit bigger base on it.
I give it a coating of water,
because, again, these stones are porous,
so it's going to soak in this clean water,
which is not going to get
any chemical down inside the stone.
We use a cleaning agent that
contains an active ingredient
known as a quaternary ammonium compound.
And it is known and respected
throughout historic
preservationists as the safest,
most effective way to clean natural stone.
This brush is made with
bristles from Tampico.
So the Tampico from the agave
plant is a natural bristle
that won't harm the natural stone.
And then I want to give it a good coating
of the D/2 Biological Solution,
which is going to go to work
on this stone very quickly.
You're going to see this stone
starting to turn a bit of an orange color.
And then it's going to
continue working on the stone
for the next few weeks,
and that stone will become
brighter and whiter and whiter.
And you have to clean them
about every two to three years.
This does a wonderful job
of getting all the growth
killed on the stone.
The next step is to let that
soak for about 10 minutes.
When I'm looking at a
headstone in a cemetery,
I want that stone to be impeccably clean.
It doesn't matter if it's almost clean.
It needs to be clean.
I think the reason why
some veteran headstones
become more soiled or more
covered in biological growth
is because of the polishing of the stone.
The more polished the stone,
the less surface area there is
for the biological organisms
to adhere to the stone.
And after about 10 minutes,
it's not that hard to get
the material off the stone
with a soft-bristle,
natural-bristle brush.
Then you can get into the
etchings with a toothbrush
to get into the real nooks and
crannies of things sometimes.
And the final step of
honoring a veteran of our past
is to place an American
flag at their grave.
This is known as a grave flag.
This particular grave has already had
an American Legion flag
holder placed at the grave,
and there's a spot in the back of them
for the flag stick to just
stick right down into it.
My vision of By Memorial Day is that
one day in the near future,
we'll have a volunteer
assigned to every
veteran's grave in America,
no matter where that veteran is buried,
no matter what cemetery they're in.
So, to tell you a little
bit about why this happens,
these are living organisms.
These are plants growing on the stone,
whether they're algae or lichens
or mold, mildew.
And so the reason why we use this
quaternary ammonium
compound is this kills them.
So these things are natural in nature.
You're going to find in
the South especially,
we have this black mold on all of our
concrete-tile roofs.
And it's not just growing on rooftops;
it's also growing on our headstones.
I think it's important that
we don't lose the stories
of our veteran heroes of the past,
because they truly are forgotten.
Their stories are disappearing
because when they pass away
and the people who knew them pass away,
their stories are pretty
much gone forever.
So, now we're going to
start on the etchings.
I start with the cross at the top
and work my way down just each letter.
These are etched into the marble.
As compared to the
early veteran headstones
known as bas-relief, where the letters
were basically sticking out,
they removed the material
around the letters.
So the letters became
kind of three-dimensional.
The material that grows
inside these stones,
it's a combination of
things fixed in there,
and also there's little
ledges, so to speak,
where when the wind
blows, the pollen falls,
all different types of
things will just get wedged
and just build up in these etchings.
Grave flags measure 8 inches by 12 inches,
but I would rather have
a flag than no flag,
so if you can't find an 8-by-12,
that doesn't mean you can't
place a flag at the grave.
The person at a podium
speaking, for example,
the American flag is to their right.
So in this case, we have a
headstone of an American veteran.
So as the veteran's looking at you,
the flag needs to be to his or her right.
You want to get as close
to the stone as you can
without marring the
stone with your mallet.
Because when the weed eaters
and other types of maintenance
equipment comes through,
you don't want them
hitting your flag holder.
The way that I research the veterans
buried beneath the veteran
headstones that I clean
is by using the internet first.
And I go to certain sources
that I know contain content,
such as findagrave.com.
There's several different
websites like that.
And by looking into
those different databases
and different family
trees on ancestry.com,
you can start to put together
the story of a veteran.
And every now and then you just
get something that's amazing
and insightful that you didn't anticipate.
This is a application
for a headstone or marker
for a deceased American veteran.
The family members would have
to complete this application
in order to choose what
style of veteran headstone
that they wanted for their loved one.
And this particular application is for
Robert S. Lewis,
prepared by his father.
And this is where the
story of his sacrifice
became apparent.
This man was a sergeant.
Sgt. Shadman was a top turret gunner.
"Fire in the cockpit. Could
not see if he got out.
I saw Sgt. Shadman
reaching for a parachute.
I do not believe he could
have gotten out alive
because the plane broke apart
where he was last seen."
When they were attacked, they
were flying at 24,000 feet.
Sgt. Shadman was up in the
top turret, he was a gunner,
and he was trying to get
out of that top turret
as the plane was tumbling to the ground.
His death's date says September 12, 1944.
But there's evidence to
suggest that he did in fact
get out of that aircraft and
he did reach the ground alive
because there's a hospital
admission record of him
in September 1944.
We don't know what day that he died,
but his mother applied
for his veteran headstone
with a death date of September 23rd.
In your local cemeteries,
there are local heroes
whose graves are in really bad condition,
and it's pretty sad that a man or a woman
gives their life for our country
and then they're forgotten in the cemetery
and their headstone can't even be read
because there's so much
biological filth on it.
There are people in America who
care about veterans' graves,
they just don't know
what's happening out here.
So I want to bring this story to them
so that they know that
in your local cemeteries,
there are local heroes whose graves
are in really bad condition.
So if this is something
that speaks to your heart,
I encourage you to get out
in your local cemetery,
see for yourself if
there's veteran headstones
in need of cleaning in your local area,
and take the initiative
to do something about it.